this is what we intended to talk about
all of the spin interesting preface what
is the actual risk space for the AI what
do we know would we not know how should
we think about it how should we proceed
especially given that AI is a lot of
different things
uh
should we dive in there now
sure I just wanted to point out that
although this seems like a disagreement
between you and I on the surface there's
an agreement so again I'm not a Mormon
but I don't see the Mormons failure
because they go and they say hey you
should whatever they say Act Right be
humble be kind don't over consume and so
on but then their religion doesn't grow
I don't see that as a failure of them
because maybe their religion is larger
than just being Mormon it's something
about the values that are spread and
then they send out these values and they
filter through the community in the same
way that these non-profits just because
they're not the largest doesn't mean
that the values that they send out don't
influence you and I and influence the
people who are listening who then act
differently because of these values we
have no idea how much the pacifism of
Tolstoy has influenced you hugging your
father and your brother and the positive
sentiment we have generally speaking in
society toward decentralization and it
also reminds me of the Cassandras for
people who don't know what a Cassandra
is it's someone who makes a prediction
it's a doomsayer it's akin to a
doomsayer they're the opposite of a
self-fulfilling belief so
self-fulfilling belief is one where you
state it and you create the conditions
such that it becomes true whereas in the
best case for the people who say the
world is going to end well their success
depends on them being self-sacrificing
depends on us then being able to
repudiate them like the world hasn't
ended we have no idea how much the
doomsayers are the fear-mongerers said
something that made us straighten up and
act right just enough that it pushed us
off of the brink and influenced us to
make Society living so we then have this
archetype of the cautious and
contamacious false Cravens of the past
it's just not clear that because they
have died doesn't mean that they're
unsuccessful that's what I mean yeah so
there's a this important Point
um the idea that
even though
Greece didn't
um
continue its Empire relative to Rome
that its memes ended up influencing the
whole Roman Empire
uh and so in some way
it won or similar with
judaic ideas or whatever one of the
greatest examples of that that people
talk about right now is Tibetan Buddhism
which is
Okay so from the point of view of
um Tibet as a nation the Tibetan people
the
Integrity of that wisdom tradition
it was radically destroyed but in the
process of the world seeing that and
having some empathy and gendered for it
even though it didn't protect
Tibet uh did that actually disseminate
Buddhist ideals so the whole world
radically faster
there's a similar conversation as uh
so many people become interested in
Ayahuasca and plant medicines from
indigenous cultures that the economic
pressure of that is making what is
remnant of those cultures get turned
into tourism in Ayahuasca production or
should people production or whatever it
is that on one hand it actually looks
like a destructive act on those cultures
in the other way it's are the memetics
of those now becoming dispersed
throughout the dominant systems
um that is a part of the consideration
set that has to be considered
um
and
now do we see for instance that
particularly non-violent
groups like say the jains as an example
of Maximum non-violence
um that those memes
do become
decentralized and affect everybody
it's it's
not a simple yes or no right there's a
whole bunch of contextual applications
so when we look at as are there memes
from Buddhism that have influenced the
world yes but are they the ones that are
compatible with the motivational set of
the world they influence
so you've got this like
Buddhist techniques of mindfulness for
capitalists and Silicon Valley to
Crusher to capitalism is a very weird
version of the subset of the Buddhist
stack right
um and I remember when I first started
seeing kind of the
um popularization of mindfulness
techniques in business so that people
could focus better in Russia to
capitalism how
[__] hilarious that thing is right
because in some ways you are
Distributing good ideas in other ways
you're actually extracting from a whole
cultural set the part that ends up being
a service ingredient to another set
um
so the topic of what makes it through I
mean it's a complex topic what I will
say is
the
idea that a
s a civilization which is its its
superstructure it's world view values
what is true good beautiful what it's
oriented to what's a good life it's
social structure meaning it's political
economy and institutions it's
formal incentives and deterrence and how
it organizes Collective Agreement and
its infrastructure the physical Tech
stack that it mediates all this on
together in a civilizational stack
one of those competing with other ones
four scarce resource and dominance
and all of them engaged in that
particular competitive thing
I would argue no one actually gets to
win that that process of the competition
of those relative to each other does
actually create an overall civil Global
civilizational topology that
self-terminates
but also no one trying to create a good
long-term future can just lose it that
game in the short term so you can
neither create the world you want by
just losing at that game nor by trying
to win at it it's something else it's
actually having to abandon that game to
try to change the game Dynamics
themselves ah okay so I was just
watching Arrested Development this that
you can't play the game you can't frame
it in the same way so Buster from arrest
development I don't know if you've seen
it he's this mama's boy he wants to go
out with this other girl who happens to
have the same name as his mom but anyway
she's like I don't want to go out with
you because you're just in love with
your mom then he's like no and he just
left his mom's home he's like 40 years
old or 35 and he's like no no it's the
opposite I'm leaving my mom for you
you're replacing my mom and then she's
like no and it's because he's still
framing it in the same way anyway we
have to abandon the frame so please what
does that look like and integrate AI
into this answer
hahaha
so we have not
just tried to give the frame on AI
risket and to in
to incorporate that in the what is the
long-term solution for civilization as a
whole look like let's actually just kind
of do the AI risk part first and then we
can bring it back together
um
let's
try to frame how to think about
AI risks AI
opportunities and potentials including
how AI can help solve other risks which
has to be factored
um
I will add as preface that I uh
I'm not an AI developer I don't have
background in that I'm not even a AI
risk expert or specialist I know you're
in conversation
um might have utkowski and other people
who really are Stuart Russell Boston all
those guys should be great
um
because of some
maybe uh
novel perspectives about thinking about
risk and governance approaches to risk
writ large meta crisis that's the
perspective that I'm taking into the AI
topic
so
um
what is unique about AI risk relative to
other risks we were talking earlier
about
environmental risks and risks associated
with uh
large-scale war and breakdown of human
systems and synthetic bio and other
things
if we look at other technologies that
are that have the potential to do some
catastrophic things like nuclear it's
very easy to see that
uh nuclear weapons don't make better bio
weapons
they don't make better cyber weapons
they don't even make better nuclear
weapons directly
and the same is true for Bio technology
it doesn't automatically make those
other things
AI is pretty unique in that you can use
AI to
evolve the state of the art and nuclear
technology in delivery technology and
intelligence technology in BIO and cyber
and literally all of them so it is
unique in its omnipurpose potential in
that way because of course all those
other Technologies were developed by
human intelligence
human intelligence agency creativity
some unique faculties of human
cognitive process
and so where all the other Technologies
are kind of the result of that human
process
building a technology that is doing that
human process possibly much faster and
on much more scale
is obviously a unique kind of case right
and
um
so there's thinking about what type of
risk does an AI system create on its own
but then they're thinking about how does
how do AI systems affect all other
categories of risk right we have to
think about both of those
um
and then in addition to the fact that
the nukes don't automatically make
better bioweapons the nukes don't even
automatically make more nukes right
they're not pattern replicating but to
the degree that we actually get
AI systems that not only can make all
the other things better but they can
make better AI systems and to the degree
that there starts to be something like
autonomy in that process then the self
upgrading and Omni potential of all the
other things
um
it's also true that uh
there's a exponential curve in
the development of Hardware that AI runs
on right better gpus and
all of different kinds of computational
capabilities there's an exponential
curve in iot systems for capturing more
data to train them on
exponentially more people and money
going into the field
uh
because of the way that shared knowledge
systems work the tent of exponential
development and the software and
cognitive architectures so we're looking
at the intersection of multiple
exponential curves not just a single one
that is also kind of important and
unique to understand about the space so
thinking about the case of AI turning
into AGI in autonomous
artificial intelligence system that we
can no longer pull the plug on that has
goals has objective functions whatever
they happen to be
that is you know something that guys
like Bostrom and utkowski have done a
very good job of describing why that's a
very risky thing I think everybody at
this point probably has a decent sense
of it but just make it very quick
we say a narrow AI system would mean
something that is trained to be good at
a very specific domain like beating
people at chess or beating them at go or
being able to summarize a large body of
text
when we say general intelligence we mean
something that
uh could maybe do all of those things
and can figure out how to be better than
humans at new domains that has not been
trained on through you know some kind of
abstraction or lateral application of
what it already knows
so if you put us into an environment
where we have to figure out how we have
to figure out what is even the Adaptive
thing to do
we will do it right there's a certain
kind of general intelligence that we
have so we talk about a generally
intelligent artificial intelligence
um the idea and then of course because
we can develop AI systems
one of the things it could do is develop
AI system so if it has more cognitive
capability than us in some ways it can
develop a better AI system and that one
could recursively develop a better one
and you get this kind of
thought about recursive takeoff in the
power of an AI system
and there are conversations about
whether that would be slow or fast
is there an upper boundary on how
intelligent a system could be in humans
or near the top of that or are we barely
scratching at the beginning of it and we
could have something millions of times
smarter than us
um
so that's all kind of part of that
conversation but the idea that we could
create a artificial intelligence that is
that could basically beat us at all
games
right they could which it could think
about economy and affecting public
opinion
and Military as games
and
uh it has faster feedback loops faster
Loops to get better than we do so if
we're like trying to deal with it it's
going to win at newly defined games
and if that thing we can't pull the plug
on and it can anticipate our movements
and beat us at all games if it has goals
that are directly antithetical to ours
or not even directly antithetical but
the way in which it fulfills its goals
might involve externalizing harm to
things that are part of our goal set
that's bad for us right so the idea of
don't let that thing happen prevents
getting to an unaligned AGI that's that
particular category of risk and so there
are arguments around could an AGI like
that is it even possible that's one
question if it is possible to have such
a thing
uh is it possible to align it with human
interests what would that take
um is it possible if it is possible to
align it is it possible to know ahead of
time that the system you have will be
aligned and will stay aligned right like
those are all some of the questions in
the space and then do our current
trajectories of AI research like
Transformer Tech or just neural networks
or deep learning in general do these
Converge on general intelligence
and
if so in what time period those are all
some of the questions regarding the AGI
risk space
now I want to talk about
uh that risk but I want to talk about
other risks using that as a example in
the space any questions or thoughts on
that one to begin with
sure number one is that we may already
have artificial intelligence into baby
form like we have hugging face I don't
know if you know what that is and then
there's the paper of Sparks of
artificial general intelligence and
that's distinguished from something that
updates itself I just want to make that
clear
so there's a lot of questions regarding
does it have to be better than humans at
everything to be an existential risk
we could imagine
we could imagine a
um
Von Neumann machine that was
self-replicating and self-evolving that
was not better at everything but better
at
turning what was around it into more of
itself and evolving its ability to do so
and just having way faster feedback
loops and we could imagine that becoming
an existential risk with a speed of a
particular type of intelligence that
does not mean better than us at
everything yeah that's a great Point
like an asteroid is not better than us
at almost anything but it can destroy us
and it yeah it's not doing it through
some kind of process that involves
learning or navigating competitions at
all it's just kinetic impact this would
be a kind of intelligence but it could
be a one that's a lot more like a very
bad pandemic right and the intelligence
of a of a pathogen then the intelligence
of a god
um so talking about if the
system is generally in like what type of
intelligence it would need is it
generally intelligent is it autonomous
is it agentic is it self-upgrading right
there they're related Concepts or
they're not identical Concepts
so what I
um so let's go ahead and put the
category of AGI risk as one Topic in the
AI risk space
um
let's come to a much nearer term set of
things which is
uh AI empowering Bad actors
and we can talk about what if that is
possible with the existing technology
what of that is possible with impending
technology that we're for sure going to
get on the current course versus things
where we don't know how long it's going
to take or even if we'll get there
so with regard to AI empowering Bad
actors we could say how undefined bad
actor is obviously it because one
person's Freedom Fighter is another
person's terrorist
um but uh uh so we can imagine someone
who is terrified about environmental
collapse deciding to become an
eco-terrorist being a maximally good
actor in their worldview but saying that
the only answer is to start taking out
massive chunks of the civilizational
system that's destroying the environment
so
um I'm simply saying that I'm not being
simplistic about what we mean by bad
actor but oriented to from whatever
motivational type whether it was pure
sadism whether it's nihilistic burn it
all down or whether it's well motivated
but maybe misguided considerations
um but AI for some destructive purpose
right so
now
ah this is something we have to address
first
one thing I have found when people think
about
how significant AI risk will be and how
significant AI upside will be
first on AI upside it's just important
because if we talk about risk and we
don't talk about upside
it will be easy for a lot of people to
say oh this is a technopessimist Luddite
perspective and kind of dismiss it at
that so I would like to say there is a
the upsides of AI the best case examples
that everyone is interested in everyone
is interested in they're awesome right
can we all the things that we care about
that we use intelligence to figure out
where intelligence is rate limiting
figure them out rate limiting to figure
out the rest of the problems could we
use it to solve those problems
so could AI make major breakthroughs in
cancer and immuno oncology and does
anyone who's talking about slowing down
AI are they factoring all the kids that
are dying of cancer right now and if we
could speed That Thing Up could we
affect that in our like
that's a very personal very real thing
right so AI applied to curing all kinds
of diseases and
um
and AI applied to psychiatric diseases
and scientific breakthroughs and
um maybe resource optimization issues
that help the environment and maybe the
ability to help with coordination
challenges if applied in certain ways
the
positive applications the kind of
customized AI tutoring
that could provide Marcus Marcus
Aurelius level education where the best
tutors of all of Rome were personally
tutoring him in every topic could
provide something better than that to
every human right could democratize
aristocratic tutoring
there was a Eric holes or essays on
aristocratic tutoring are really good
you should bring them on here but
basically it was a
something many people have come to which
is that the great polymaths and super
Geniuses the highest statistical
correlator that pops out is that they
all had something like aristocratic
tutoring when they were young or the
vast majority of them that even the
annoyman and Einstein had mathematicians
as governances before they went to
school
and um Terry Tower had Paul Erdos
there's this famous image of I don't
know who had Edwin though
so that is a
um many of many of the people simply had
parents that were very actively involved
scientists philosophers thinkers you
know but um
but if you think about why Marcus Riley
has dedicated the whole first chapter of
meditations to his tutors
um and if you think about how the Dalai
Lama was conditioned where you find the
three old boy and have the top
llamas and all of Tibet two to them on
everything that is the whole Canon of
knowledge of course if that was applied
to everybody we'd have a very different
world right this is very interesting
Insight because it says that the upper
boundaries on a lot of what we call
human nature because the ubiquitous it's
not nature it's nature through
ubiquitous conditioning that the edge
cases on human behavior Show
conditioning in common
and that if you could make that kind of
conditioning ubiquitous you would
actually change the Human Condition
pretty profoundly but as we move from
feudalism to democracy and wanted to
kind of get rid of all the Dreadful
unequal aspects of feudalism looking at
the fact that
like you can't learn to be a world-class
mathematician by a person who's not a
world-class mathematician the same way
you can by one who is and you can't you
don't get a bunch of world-class
mathematicians becoming third grade or
eighth grade high school teachers you
know or School teachers so how would you
do that so it's kind of repugnant from a
privileged lack of democratized
capability point of view right
and yet could you have
could I make
llm trained AIS and better than llm ones
where I can have Von Neumann and
Einstein and girdle all in a
conversation with me about formal logic
where they are not only representing
their ideas but maybe even now have
access to all the ideas since then
and are pedagogically regulating
themselves to my learning style
that's kind of amazing right like
um and could they maybe be doing that
based on also
uh psychological development theories uh
colleague mine Zack Stein has been
working on this a lot of how to be
evolving not just their cognitive
capacity but their psychosocial moral
aesthetic ethical Etc full Suite of
human capacities
so I'm simply saying a AI applied
rightly there's a lot of things to be
excited in I'm optimistic about in
so that's a given and we could do a
whole long conversation on more of those
examples
um there is a
when when I look at how people Orient to
the topic of AI risk
one of the things that seems to be a
common kind of where their knee-jerk
reactions before understanding all the
arguments Pro and Conwell comes is how
much they've they have a bias towards a
kind of techno optimism or
technopessimism kind of a where
um Pinker hondrossling there are still
problems but they're getting better the
world is getting progressively better
and it's a result of things like
capitalism and technology and science
and progress and so more of that will
just keep equaling better and yes there
will be problems but they're worth it
right versus so that's
I would call that
um
techno Capital optimism program but the
naive version that doesn't look at the
cost of that thing we would call a naive
progress dialectic
um
in the dialectic of
progress is good progress is not good
um or we're really making progress
versus we're actually losing critical
things or causing harm or whatever say
in that dialectic that's on the progress
side that a naive version of it
um and so most of the
and just to address that briefly
um
so then the naive progress story looks
at all the things that have gotten
better and you can see this in lots of
good books and pinker's books
diamandis's books rosslings talks on and
on and then the extension of that into
the future diamand to start to do and we
could say Kurzweil is kind of an
extension of that far out
um
why naive is if it doesn't look at what
is lost in that process and what is
harmed in that process as well as the
increase in the types of risk that are
happening
and so I would argue that most of those
things in every kind of wrestling
presentation is cherry picking its data
out of a humongous set to make a
cherry-picked argument this is one of
the reasons that fact checking is not
enough is because you can cherry pick
your facts you can frame them in a
particular way and create a conclusion
that the totality of knowledge wouldn't
support it all
because of that process right
um
I would say there is a naive
technopessimism or Luddite direction
that looks at the real harms Tech causes
culturally socially environmentally or
other things and uh
wants back to the land of movement and
organic natural
traditional whatever various types of
and
if it is not paying attention to the
types of benefit that are legitimate
that's naive but if also if it's not
paying attention to the fact that that
worldview will simply as we talked about
before not forward itself because the
one that advances more Tech will develop
more power and end up becoming the
dominant World System
um that also means that it's not
actually having a world view that can't
Orient or just shaping the world
so we have to
so putting those together I would say
all of the things that the Techno
optimists say Tech has made better and
all of us like world were going to the
dentist involved novocaine versus not
not novocaine and where we have
painkillers and where we have
antibiotics under infection and stuff
like that
all of the things that Tech has made
better
have not come for free there have been
externalized costs
and the cumulative effect of all of
those costs is really really significant
and so if you look at the progress
narrative
the indigenous people that were
genocided don't see it's a progress
narrative the fact that there are more
there's more biomass of animals in
factory farms than there is in the wild
today does not see that as a sign of
progress
the animals that live in factory farms
or all the species that are extinct
don't see it as progress
the fact that we have many many
different possibilities of destroying
the life support
capacity of the planet relative to any
previous time
or that almost no teen girl growing up
in the industrialized world doesn't have
body dysmorphia
um where that was not ubiquitous thing
there's a lot of things where you can
say damn those Technologies upregulated
some things and externalize costs
somewhere else
if you factor the totality of that then
you
can say okay there are a lot of positive
examples any new type of tech can have
but there's also a lot of externalities
and harms it can have and we want to see
how to get more of the upsides with less
of the downsides and that can't be a
rush forward process right that actually
requires a lot of thinking about how to
do that so I'm actually
I actually am a techno Optimist in a way
meaning I I do see a future that
um is high nature stewardship High
um
and there's also High Tech High touch
yeah meaning
um
that the tech does not move us into
being disembodied heads mediating
exclusively through a digital world but
am
so I would argue that
your online relationships don't do
everything that offline relationships do
they do some additional things like
distance and network Dynamics whatever
but if they debase your embodied
relationships they're causing a harm if
they if the online relationships improve
your embodied relationships
not just the create online relationships
and debase them then that's a different
thing right so that's what I mean by
high touch
um
so
I want to say
that naive techno optimism
is
if there's you know if we look at the
history of corporations that are
developing technology Market technology
advancement focused on the upside and
um not terribly focused on the downside
we look at four out of five doctors
choose camless cigarettes
we look at Better Living Through
Chemistry providing
DDT and parathione and malathione we
look at adding lead to gasoline in a way
that tooks it talks a chemical that was
bound in ore underneath the biosphere
and sprayed it into the atmosphere
ubiquitously and dropped about a billion
IQ points off the planet made everybody
more violent in terms of its
neurotoxicology effects
um
trusting the groups that are making the
upside on moving the thing to figure out
the risks historically is not a very
good idea now mentioning that in terms
of now trusting the AI groups to do
their own risk assessment
um and if you think about the totality
of risks well then you want to say how
do we move the positive applications of
this technology forward in a way that
mitigates the really negative
applications of it that if one wants to
be a techno-optimist responsibly they
have to be thinking about that well
so what about the AI companies that say
we do third party testing for safety do
you still consider that somehow internal
because they're the ones going out
depends
um
if so
when I early in the process of getting
into risk assessment I had times where
corporations asked me to come do risk
assessment on a technology or process
and then when I did an honest risk
assessment they were not happy because
what they wanted me to do was some kind
of box checking exercise that wouldn't
cost them very much and wouldn't limit
what they were going to do so they had
plausible deniability to say they had
done the thing and move forward quickly
because what they didn't want was me to
say actually there is no way for you to
pursue the market viability of this that
does not cause excessive harms or were
you dealing with those harms messes up
your possibility for margins
without breaking any NDA of yours that
you may have signed are you able to go
into what a company did that you
disapproved of and what was the result
of it
just as an example to make this more
concrete for people who are listening
yeah totally
um I have seen this in
the example of something like uh
mining technology that it or a new type
of packaging technology that is wanting
to say why it's doing something that
addresses some of the environmental
concerns
IT addresses the environmental concerns
it identified when we identify a bunch
of other ones that it doesn't address
well that it moves some of the harm from
this area to the other one that's an
example of where some of the problem
would come but I find this is just as
bad in the non-profit space or in the
government space as well not just in the
for-profit space because they also have
if it even if it's not a profit motive
they have an Institutional mandate and
their institutional mandate is narrow
they can advance that narrow thing this
is now the same thing as an AI objective
right if the AI has an objective
function
to optimize X whatever X is or optimize
a weighted function of
XYZ and metrics
everything that falls outside of that
set harm can be externalized to that and
achieve its objective function so I
remember
talking to groups you and Associated
groups they were working on world hunger
and their particular Solutions involved
bringing conventional agriculture to
areas in the world that didn't have it
which meant
all of the pesticide herbicides and
nitrogen fertilizers and it was a huge
increase in nitrogen fertilizer by a
bunch of river deltas
yeah where it currently wasn't that
would increase dead zones and oceans
from that nitrogen affluent
um that would affect the Fisheries in
those areas and everything else and the
total biodiversity and when I brought it
up to them they're like oh I guess
that's true but those are not the
metrics we're tasked with you know we're
tasked with how many people get fed this
year not how much the environment is
ruined in the process
and so the reduction of the totality of
an interconnected world to a finite set
of metrics we're going to optimize for
whether it's one metric called net
profit or GDP
or it's the uh
metric of whatever the institution is
tasked with or getting elected or
something like that
um it is entirely possible to advance
that metric at the cost of other ones
and then it's entirely possible that
uh other groups who see that create
counter responses to that who do the
same thing in opposite directions and
the totality of human behavior
optimizing narrow metrics while both
driving arms races and externalizing
metrics and wide areas is at the heart
of the coordination failures we face
and so it happens to be that this is
already something that we see with
humans outside of AI but giving an AI an
objective function
is the same type of issue right so I was
mentioning
examples in the non-profit space I think
there are examples of how to do AI
safety it can also be dangerous
and
um
so it's important
sure
um
so somebody proposes an idea like here's
a type of AI that could be good and we
should build it or on the other side
here's a
AI safety protocol that would be good
and we should instead instantiate it in
regulation or whatever
um we want to Red Team those ideas
meaning see how they break or fail and
violet team them meaning see how they
externalize harm somewhere else that
they didn't intend before implementing
them which just means think through the
causal set beyond the obvious set you're
intending it for
right
um
so there was this call for a six month
pause on
training large language models bigger
than gpt4
um I'm not saying that a pause is a bad
idea I'm saying as instantiated
it's not implementable and it's not
obviously good when so you saw the
pushback because people were like all
right so that means that whatever actors
are not included in this which might
mean Bad actors uh Rush ahead relatives
um
that's a real consideration and one has
to say okay so are we
stopping the accumulation of larger GPU
clusters during that time are we
stopping the development of larger
access to larger data sets during that
time that we'll be able to quickly
configure them are we also stopping
you know there are plenty of other types
of AI that are not llms being deployed
to the public but that are very powerful
blackrock's Aladdin played some role in
the fact that it has more
um assets under management than the GDP
of the United States
and
uh there are military application ai's
in development and so
um can you in so what is the actual risk
space and are we talking about slowing
the whole thing or are we talking about
slowing some parts relative to other
parts where these kind of game theoretic
questions emerge how would we ensure
that the whole Space was slowing how
would we enforce that those are all
things that have to be considered
you mentioned that GDP is not a great
indicator and
GDP goes up with war and more military
manufacturing it goes up with increased
consumerism and the cost of the
environment it goes up with addiction
addiction is great for lifetime value of
a customer
so
there's something called good Hearts law
so I'm sure you're familiar with is this
at the core of what you're saying is
like hey
go ahead and explain that as soon as you
have a metric that you try to optimize
for it ceases to become a good metric
for instance I think this is from The
Simpsons but it may be real that there
is a town overrun by snakes or rats I
think it was rats and then you say hey
give me rat tails because it implies
that you kill the rat I'll give you a
dollar every time you bring me a rat
tail we'll reduce the amount of rats
maybe it initially did so but then
people realize I can Farm rats and then
just kill them and give you tails and
thus I have more total rats this is a
much more General phenomenon so perhaps
if you think Twitter followers are great
okay yeah if you incentivize any metric
there are perverse forms of fulfilling
that metric meaning there's a way to
fulfill that metric that either no
longer provides the good or it provides
the good while also affecting some other
bats right which basically means you
probably
thought of that metric in a specific
context right like there's a bunch of
wild rats and the only way to get a rat
tail is to kill a wild rat not in the
context of farmed rats
um and so it kind of relates to the
topic we were mentioning earlier about
government that it's not just
instantiating a government that makes
sense on the current landscape but
recognizing the landscape is going to
keep changing and it'll change in a way
that
has an incentive to
figure out how to control the regulatory
systems
um and how to gain the metric systems
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy